if you go back and watch the fight first
round cersei drops him right drops him
he's pretty wobbled so is he clear as
day first round
second round if you want to give it to
robert whitaker because he got his back
for
10 seconds
you know um okay let's give him a second
round third round and get busy fourth
round get busy then fifth round robert
whittaker all day so
uh one clears day five claire's day for
robert whitaker it's rounds two three
and four depending on your judge and how
you're gonna decide to win or those
fights especially the second round
that would dictate the entire fight
because i i i think you'd have a hard
time giving robert whitaker three rounds
i'd love to hear
kind of the explanation how you give
them three rounds
those two three and four are close
but if we're going off of what
especially the judge's main criteria
which is damage done
you know izzy definitely did the most
damage if you look at leg kicks and he
looked that front lead leg of robert
whittaker he also the head kick he did
block one but he blocked it with one
hand anyone who's been the game long
enough
you know if you block with one hand a
you have a better chance of breaking
your goddamn arm because you need both
to support the kick the force of the
kick
b
if when it's one hand the kick still
rocks your brain so izzy landed i think
two kicks when robert defended with one
hand and then also the body shot hurt
robert whittaker so
if you go through complete damage done
round by round i don't know how you
don't have izzy still retaining his
title i don't get the uproar again i
think a lot of it is you guys lost money
better than robert whittaker and i get
it that's frustrating
but you know to criticize
bizbingo he's biased
dude bisping's there also
bisping was a middleweight champion of
the world
you know so
i know you guys watch a lot of fights
but let's kind of lean into the experts
here bisping knows what the hell he's
doing he's watched a lot more fights
than you also has fought in there at the
highest level and was a world champion
so from bisping's perspective
ndc's for that matter because dc goes
man i don't get either i thought it was
pretty clear it is the opposite
best seat in the house i mean bismi had
the exact same thoughts like this is a
clearance day win for izzy he was in my
head when i'm going up to interview him
i'm thinking
did izzy win three rounds of four
definitely lose more than three right or
definitely you know didn't lose more
than two rounds i can see him give him
the fifth maybe the second but even the
seconds a little dicey so
in the judge's eyes is it four rounds
for izzy or three it's like i knew he
won the fight
so yeah dc backing up what bisping says
obviously bisping's one thing that makes
him great is he's very strong his
opinions which i love i hate when people
are trying to please both
both sides that never works out for
anybody you gotta double down on what
the [ __ ] you think and what you stand
for especially in today's society so i
think this being going hard in the paint
and going you know this is claire's day
izzy won this fight four to one
tough to disagree with him but again i
know you guys probably lost money on it
or
you know you love robert whittaker how
can you not the guy's humble even in
defeat
so i get it or maybe not an easy fan so
i get it
now that's real and your uproar on
twitter will be it's probably over by
now i bet it was uproar saturday night
sunday morning got a little dicey for a
few guys outside that over now
that's the way the news cycle works so
no one gives a [ __ ] and when it comes
it's very black and white is he won the
fight
so you can cry all you want doesn't
change anything is he won that fight
i have you know i'm fine three to two
i'm fine with three to two
four to one sure if you want you wanna
just give robert the the last round all
right he definitely won that last round
there's an argument there it's that
second round uh depending you know how
you view the fight and then you know i
guess three and four
it'd be easy